politics should not be your life
government should be so small that it
can't do everything you want and it
can't take everything from you you know
partly
[Applause]
partly what the what the left did here
was they made everything about politics
right they wake up and what can we fight
about and what can the government do and
all of these things and they believe in
essence that the government is god that
everything that is right in front of you
on any given day that that is the truth
and that is real and that's why you must
fight and at the same time you got to
fight nazis and by god all of your
political opponents are nazis and it's
all just nonsense so whether
your framework for living
outside of that is through religion or
philosophy or whatever works for you or
your family unit you have to have
something that sits much bigger that
politics is just right inside of but the
day that they trick us all to think that
politics is the answer to everything is
the day we lose
what up yo i'm dave rubin it is july 26
2022. this is the reuben report we are
live streaming on rumble youtube and
blaze tv and who was that guy making all
that sense over at turning point student
action summit in tampa this past weekend
we wanted to show you just a little
snippet of my speech we're working on
getting the the full video there but we
thought that would be a nice way to
start the show today because the
government shouldn't be that big it
shouldn't be on your back you should
live freely as you wish and that is sort
of
the tone of today's show we'll get into
the specifics uh on that in just a
second but tonight people if you're
looking to do something special the
blaze has a special for you they've got
a special for your special evening it's
called uncensored the alarming truth of
covid vaccines this was done by glenn
beck and his really fantastic staff and
blaze guys they really dive in to the
topic well they dive into all topics uh
deeply and thoughtfully and uh and
really it's it's a full look at what is
going on with the vaccines side effects
how this was pushed on us mandates and
much more it's out tonight at 9pm
eastern you can go to blazetv.com
uncensored use promo code unsafe for 20
20. off your first year subscription uh
so what we're going to be talking about
mostly today
is how the democrat playbook this
playbook that was sort of what i was
referencing in that speech that
everything is about politics at all time
and everything must be hysterical and
everything must be fought
that it's not really working that the
hysteria is starting to wear out on
people that you cannot
maintain
the level of political insanity
all the time you can sort of keep it
going for a while and you can keep the
temperature hot for a while but
eventually people start realizing oh
another crisis oh this is another nazi
i'm fighting another thing and it's just
like it doesn't work and then of course
they always find new tricks but it's not
really working they are revealing their
playbook for the election
it's radical it's dangerous you guys see
it but the good news is that most
americans know
just that so that's what we're going to
be talking about today let me get to
ramp real quick and then we will get to
it uh if you guys want a better way to
simplify your business finances across
expenses payments and accounting then
ramp is a complete game changer ramp is
a corporate card and financial software
suite designed to help you save time and
put money back in your pocket the
product gives finance terms finance
teams unprecedented control and insight
into company spend with ramp you're able
to create budgets issue cards to every
employee with limits and restrictions
and automate expense reporting so you
can stop wasting time at the end of the
month ramps accounting software
automatically collect collects receipts
and categorizes your expenses in real
time so that you don't have to the the
time you'll save each month on employee
expenses will allow you to close your
books in days not weeks it's easy to use
get started issue virtual and physical
cards and start making payments in less
than 15 minutes whether you have five
employees or five thousand and now get
two hundred fifty dollars when you join
ramp just go to ramp.com reuben that's
ramp ramp.com reuben and now back to
me
okay so the democrats i don't like these
people very much i used to be one of
them i think my mom's one of them so i
like some of them to some degree i think
a lot of them are very confused not
really sure what happened they think
that the democrat party is still the
democrat party of say 30 35 years ago
which it ain't in case you're not
playing at home uh the democrats have
just run this rampant wild spend
everything government will do everything
lock you down destroy your life policy
defund the police okay you get all that
stuff uh and it's not working and the
polls are showing it's not working so
cnn is now starting to have to figure
out well how do we talk about this
because gosh darn it we're going to lose
the election because cnn obviously is a
bunch of democrats so jake tapper who is
a you know quote-unquote journalist but
he's in essence he's a democrat he had a
panel with a bunch of democrats talking
about what the democratic strategy
has been and and if it's working and
things got a little weird
is it not democrats playing with fire
because oh no doubt polls in
pennsylvania
you are correct masteriano was winning
even before josh shapiro the democratic
nominee started running ads about him
but
is it not playing with fire when the
democratic governors association boosts
these elections no no there's no doubt
we're playing with fire is it playing
with fire
uh i'm gonna i love yes or no questions
okay
are they playing with fire sure but it
is a republican base that is voting for
people who deny the results of the last
election want to criminalize abortion
and will only make sure that the people
they support for president
if you believe that trump represents
some kind of a crisis to democracy you
can't in good faith make those ads and
then still ask center right republicans
to believe you that you are 100
okay so there's a reason that i wanted
to show you a clip from cnn and i should
have apologized before airing it um
they're trying to figure out what to do
about these republicans who are gaining
steam and a lot of republicans who are
gaining steam whether whether you like
them or not they're they are backed by
trump they're sort of these america
first republicans uh there they were
talking about this masteriano guy uh in
pennsylvania but then you have other
people like blake masters who i like a
lot obviously who i think is going to be
the next senator from arizona and carrie
lake who's been on the show who i think
is going to be the next governor of
arizona there's jd vance in ohio that
there's these people who are
trump-backed and once you get trump back
in essence what they want to say is that
you're a white supremacist then a bigot
and an election denier and everything
else now of course what's funny about
the their election deniers these are the
very same people i mean jake tapper if
he had any degree
of of humility he would he would say
well gosh guys you know you are saying
that about the election denial but i did
run for four years running this program
with the election donors on every day we
had all these cia people who made up all
this stuff in the dossier and for four
years you know hillary clinton trump is
an illegitimate president and all of the
lies that they did and then hiding the
hunter by the laptop and all that stuff
but obviously they don't really they're
not very good at looking in the mirror
and seeing what they're doing of course
that's part of that's part of the game
so
they fear that she also said that woman
the first woman said something that they
want to criminalize abortion and it's
like that's really not what's going on
here uh you guys know that the reversal
of roe v wade was simply putting
something back to the states that was
the right of the states in the first
place meaning that the states are
supposed to do most of the stuff there
was no federal right uh in the in the
constitution to abortion we all know
that the word abortion is not in there
and now the states will do what they do
uh will some states make abortion
outright criminal there might be two or
three states and you will be allowed to
leave those states to have an abortion
if so but most states are you can see it
you can see it right now if you can just
look through the thin veil of nonsense
that they're putting on you most states
are doing fairly moderate things
you guys know my feelings about florida
florida is the model for the country
really right now if america is going to
continue america needs to be more like
florida florida which is a red state
with a red governor who we'll obviously
talk more about in just a moment uh has
a 15-week ban a three and a half month
ban on abortion and guess what the
pro-life people aren't complaining and
really although the pro-choice p you
know the blue people in florida which if
you're blue in florida i don't know what
you're doing
they're they're complaining but it's not
like a war going on here over it because
most sane people and i'm not talking
about the really like the absolute
pro-life people and i'm not talking
about the nine-month abortion people
post-birth abortion people most people
understand that negotiation between your
personal religious belief and then of
course what public policy has
has to be so what's going on here
basically is just endless fear-mongering
if if it's going to be any trump-back
candidate that wins they're going to
have to be white supremacists and bad
people and election deniers and they're
probably insurrectionists and all sorts
of stuff so since that's not really
working since the false cries of racism
and all that stuff's not working what do
you gotta do you gotta bring back kovid
it's back baby and fauci who took about
two months off from being on tv he got
uh coveted while he was taking some time
off even though he's twice vaxxed and
double boosted and god knows what else
they're injecting him with probably some
of the same cocktail that keeps biden
awake uh fauci is suddenly back
and that he dares even show his face is
just beyond imagination and he is now
going on television saying if only they
had pushed for more restrictions it
wouldn't have got this bad we know now
two and a half years later
that anywhere from 50 to 60 percent
of the transmission occur from someone
without symptoms either someone who
never will get symptoms
or someone who is in the pre-symptomatic
stage
had we known that then
the insidious nature of spread in the
community would have been much more of
an alarm and there would have been much
much more
stringent
uh restrictions in the sense of very
very heavy encouraging people to wear
masks
physical distancing or what have you
i don't know what to call the guy beyond
an authoritarian psychopath what else
could you possibly say now first off
that he didn't know they didn't know
back then that asymptomatic people were
spreading covet now first off if you're
asymptomatic
you're feeling pretty good so if you
have covid and you're asymptomatic who
cares
who cares a test comes back and it goes
oh you got covert and you're going well
i feel pretty good
i'm gonna go continue with my life and
many people got coveted and felt
completely fine so that's number one now
i suppose yes you could be asymptomatic
and spread it to someone who could catch
it okay fine just like anything else you
might have a cough or the flu or
something like that and walk into a
store and get someone sick it's part of
life right and we have immune systems
for this reason humans and their bodies
blood cells and things of that nature
immunity and then you know contacting
with the real world and you know [ __ ]
gonna happen that's kind of that's kind
of how it works the idea that he says
that whether it was about asymptomatic
people or not that he in retrospect they
should have done more stringent
lockdowns more masking and everything
else they fired doctors they fired
nurses they fired it doesn't matter what
your job was all of us are essential
i know i'm a crazy radical right-wing
extremist i believe all humans are
essential and they fired the not only
the people that they first deem
non-essential but then they fire the
people that they were deeming essential
when those essential people didn't want
to get their experimental uh injection
which of course turned out not to work
as promised and some people are saying
now it doesn't even work at all and it's
actually making people more uh more
basically
susceptible to covid okay so
the idea that he could possibly look
back he should be so shamed this man
should be so shamed and he is the
highest paid person in the federal
government he makes about 420
grand a year working for the federal
government and that he basically says no
we should have done more
we should have done more and it's not
just that we should have done more back
then he wants to bring back masks and
the rest of it look at this who are in a
zone
or a or a or a county state or a city
that has a very high
level of dynamic of viral circulation
the cdc would recommend strongly
that you wear a mask in a congregate
indoor setting
and that would include schools places of
work
anything that brings people together in
a closed
environment
that is good
public health practice
okay
now
if you are elderly or immunocompromised
or all this stuff and you guys know this
everyone knows this already right
everyone knows this then you should take
whatever precautions you see fit if
that's avoiding crowds if that's wearing
a mask whatever the idea that the cdc
would still be pushing all of this stuff
that he dare goes out there as a
representative technically i guess he
works at the nih but he talks about what
cdc guidance is that he dares go out
there and still two and a half years
later is telling people to socially
distance and wear masks and get the
vaccines and all those things it's like
man you should have been fired you
should if all of the [ __ ] that you told
us for two and a half years work then we
wouldn't be in this situation would be
would we unless call me crazy you guys
want a perpetual
uh crisis
and it not only will be a covid related
perpetual crisis but it eventually will
be a climate-related perpetual crisis
and then alien invasion perpetual crisis
zombie apocalypse
uh perpetual crisis i've been watching
resident evil on netflix it's just they
want more and more and more but you can
tell that aside from covid policy
there's a shift in political
sentiment on covid from the democrats uh
and you can see it very obviously uh
because as you know a couple days ago
joe biden got coveted now he told
everybody that he got cancer turned out
that that was just because of the
dementia but he did actually get covid
and conor put together this great video
what you're going to see here the first
half of what you're going to see is
whoopi goldberg on the view talking
about uh donald trump when he got kovid
and then we are going to juxtapose my
favorite word we are going to juxtapose
that with whoopi goldberg on the view
talking about when joe biden got coveted
he's the head of the free world so he's
whatever they're giving him
they're giving him to pump him up and
make him look like he ain't sick i guess
he's forgotten he says he gets it now
you can't possibly get it you didn't go
through it you whatever you have or
whatever you got
they got to you and they they gave you
everything you needed to do but
everybody else the rest of the people in
the united states of america don't get
to do what you do
right before the show we found out that
president biden has coveted and is
experiencing mild symptoms he's
isolating at the white house and uh i'm
sure we all wish him a speedy recovery
i wish i was isolating at the white
house can you bring me a grilled cheese
i mean the good news is is that he's
double boosted he's fully vaccinated
this is a very situation a very
different situation than when the former
president had coveted before
he was vaccinated and you know
that sort of thing oh sonny she is such
a dullard yeah that's right biden is
double vaxxed and double boosted and he
still got coveted trump was not vaxxed
when he got coveted and he was basically
back in action 24 hours later despite
the fact that most people
in the media were not wishing him well
the amount of people that were that were
hoping and praying for his death on
twitter and elsewhere was through the
roof but i just wanted to show you that
just because i know you get it but it's
like just showing you the general tone
it was like when trump got it it was
like sort of his fault that he got it
even though he was the guy that got
operation warp speed to get all the
vaccines out there you may not like the
vaccines now or wanted to take a vaccine
but like for these people who are
vaccine worshipers right they're science
worshipers that you'd think they'd be a
little thankful for trump i mean they're
literally saying oh but it's very
different because you know biden got the
vaccine he's been jabbed 87 times that
had a little something to do with trump
but when it was trump got it it was like
there was a certain anger towards trump
uh but when biden got well we wish him
well and you know hopefully as if they
as if they let biden hold a phone to
order a grilled cheese there's no chance
in hell but the thing is they need trump
they need trump and that's why the the
2024 race is so complex because the the
media cnn msnbc the view abc cbs all
that stuff their ratings are dumping out
and what is the thing
that could get their ratings going again
it's the thing they hate most and that's
why this is a match made in hell it's
donald trump that simply
is true so then of course this brings us
to well is trump going to run what's he
thinking all that stuff well donald
trump spoke at turning point
student action summit on saturday and uh
he sort of dropped some hints
the fake news media is totally complicit
in this whole
deal and if i renounced my beliefs
if i agreed to stay silent if i stayed
home if i announced that i was not going
to run for office
the persecution
of donald trump
would immediately stop we know that
everybody knows that
but that's
what they want me to do
and you know what
there's no chance i do that there's just
no chance i do but i can't do it
[Applause]
all right so that kind of sounds like
you're running right like i'm gonna keep
fighting i'm gonna keep going he's
giving these political speeches this the
general sentiment from what i'm hearing
and
in my little world is that he is gonna
run and then of course there's still
this issue between him and desantis and
can they break bread can they figure
this thing out is there a way that they
can come together do they need to have
it out is that the best thing that could
happen all of that stuff
but trump is a piece he's actually like
a physical piece in a way
if you looked at if you just opened
their knapsack of stuff that the
democrats have having trump in the
knapsack is right there it's right there
because they need him so that they can
paint the rest of us as insurrectionists
and racists and all of that stuff and
because he gets clicks and views uh and
he basically stands in defense of
everything that they hate like sort of
america uh we're going back to the view
jesus here's anna navarro saying how
trump is worse than desantis
i live in florida and
as many issues as i have with desantis i
don't think it's the same thing because
i don't think desantis has been involved
in promoting a coup
against america and then being part of
the organization so i do not yet well
so okay when he does then i'll have that
issue with him yeah but until now i
don't think i i think i think donald
trump is in a class all by himself thank
god thank god there's only one donald
trump
so there's something so interesting
going on here first off that okay anna
and i'm i'm told again that i live
fairly close to hannah navarro so i'm
going to see her one day while i'm
walking clyde and he has uh the scent of
the view women on him and it's like what
he does i don't know what can i i can't
stop him how he got the sense of the
view ladies i can't i can't tell you
super deal
but anna what she's saying there is sort
of interesting so donald trump of course
donald trump caused a coup now let's
remember the coup which had no leader it
had no plans they brought no weapons uh
the
officers at the capitol let everybody in
there were some grandmas that took
selfies a bunch of that kind of stuff
and then yes a few a few bad people were
there of course too who were being held
on trial indefinitely and a whole bunch
of other stuff uh i you know isolated uh
punishment and all that okay fine uh but
joy's response to he hasn't started a
coup not yet
that's what joy said not yet so you can
see what they're doing trump right now
still looms the largest right he's the
orangist he's the biggest his hair is
the craziest he's the number one threat
but you can see what they will do to
desantis and i think this is the key
thing for anyone who is not a woke lefty
or a democrat anyone who's willing to go
against the machine what they did to
donald trump they will do to you and
what i mean by that actually is not just
anyone who's in politics if whatever it
is that you do in your life if you stand
up to the thing they will throw
everything they got it yet that's what
cancer culture is all about that's what
this fear is all about that's what this
revolution or i would say this
counter-revolution against their
revolution is all about so desantis will
be painted as he's just as bad as trump
but
he's more competent so he's even worse
that's the new thing the new yorker
magazine just did a big piece on that
that he's got all of the policies of
trump but he knows how to staff and he
knows how to actually execute trump is
just shooting from the hip doesn't
really know what he's doing so he's even
worse so that's going to be a sort of
blend that we're going to constantly see
there
and then of course the other thing that
they're going to constantly be pushing
is liz cheney because there is nothing
that the media loves more than a pet
republican a republican who will go on
television to tell you how bad
republicans are and who never
accomplishes nor conserves anything uh
and this is interesting a little more
from the view man we're really putting
them through it today i feel like i owe
you guys a drink
uh this is this charlemagne
the god guy i can't call him that i
can't call him that so when i can't call
someone else god it's blasphemy man so
apparently his name is leonard mcelvee
okay so some people call him charlemagne
the god his name's leonard okay
it's cool fine so here's leonard on the
view
uh and they're asking him about about
liz jd okay
we were talking about politics and we
were talking about liz cheney
and there's some people like me who see
her as a profile in courage as a
historical figure uh as somebody who's
supposed this is cheney yes how do you
see her
not none of those things i mean i don't
i don't i mean that's a broad question
how do i see her like yeah because some
people see her as a hero in today's
politics no some people see her as a
serum well she's standing up to people
who say that
pretty low i mean
yeah but she was complicit for four
years i mean when you ride with donald
trump on damn near everything for four
years i don't think you can be
considered a hero
all right so leonard look i'm not really
into what you're saying there either
it's just interesting to watch this it's
like anna no wants him to be like yes
trump's the worst liz cheney's the worst
and he's like wait a minute but liz kind
of liked trump so i don't know about
that also i don't know what leonard's
talking about like what she ran you know
she was with trump she rode with trump
for four years and bo what what happened
well we had no wars remember that no war
thing that was pretty good we had lowest
all-time
black and latino unemployment that was
pretty good remember that that was
pretty good he was the first first-term
president to ever come in uh for
marriage equality that seemed pretty
good uh things were going quite well you
could go to creightonbarrel.com and
order a chair that would come in the
same calendar year that was pretty good
so it's just sort of funny watching
these people operate but there's nothing
more that people like anna navarro sort
of the just these generic you know
rotating cast of nothingness people that
are in mainstream media there's nothing
more than they love than that pet
republican who goes on these shows says
what they want they get a cookie they
get pat on the head sometimes on the
butt and they get out of there so here
is uh liz cheney uh who's about to lose
her congressional seat by the way uh
she's gonna lose it to harriet hageman
who i had on the show because the people
uh hate her up there um
she uh she is now of course being asked
about running in 2024 despite having
literally no support except anna navarro
i haven't really uh
at this point i have not made a decision
about
2024
and i am really very focused on on the
substance of what we have to do on the
select committee uh very focused on the
work that i have to do to represent the
people of wyoming um and i'll make a
decision about 2024 down the road
you really need to understand this no
offense to the people in wyoming
wyoming's actually quite lovely state
i've only driven through it twice and
stopped once briefly
but it is a huge state it is an energy
producing state there are good people
who live there it has one it has one
congressional seat that's it that's the
one the only reason you know of liz
cheney obviously it partly is because of
her last name her dad was the vp got us
into i remember the iraq war and you
remember all that and his connections to
the companies that were rebuilding and
all the money and all that stuff okay
fine but the only reason you really know
anything about liz cheney right now is
she's giving the democrats and the media
exactly what they want and if you give
them exactly what they want they will
start talking about you as a
presidential candidate there is
literally nobody there is nobody who is
a liz cheney supporter
nobody do you guys know when he lives
chat you guys are out there you guys are
out there you're younger than me you're
out every night you go out to the bars
and things people are talking about liz
cheney
nothing you're not seeing the loose
cheney bumper stickers nobody's talking
about liz cheney but the media loves liz
cheney because what would she be she'd
be an anti-trump republican who would
accomplish absolutely nothing who would
then obviously lose in the presidential
race
i mean the rules of the game are just so
obvious it's ridiculous speaking of
other pet republicans who get absolutely
nothing done here's adam kinzinger and
this loser he's on his way out he's not
even running for reelection because he
just became such a stooge and a tool uh
here he is this is astute political
analysis analysis uh here he is just
saying that the republicans are awful
his own party uh the republicans are
just terrible and they're mean and bad
and not good very people i don't like
them what's your take on that the state
right now of the republican party that
that can be the case despite everything
the hearings have laid out over the past
few months
yeah the state of the party's a disaster
i mean look there are there are
anecdotal i have people that tell me you
know hey my dad was addicted to fox news
never thought anything wrong with donald
trump now he hates him because of these
hearings i hear anecdotal things like
that
guys he literally heard someone's dad
say something
how was that how did they not throw the
breaking news chiron on that kinzinger
talked to somebody about their dad what
is going on here these people watching
these programs they're all bananas
somebody's dad i anecdotally heard that
someone's dad said something i better
get on msnbc and tell other people about
other people have dads this whole thing
is going to come together jesus christ
this guy thinks that people care more
about january 6th and ukraine than crime
then inflation then gas prices all of
the stuff that we know that people
actually care about but that's why they
keep putting them on oh you don't do
anything about anything and you you
demonize the side that maybe is fighting
back also this idea that the republican
party is in shambles or whatever i gotta
tell you i was just at the sunshine
summit as you guys know which is the
republican party annual gala
get together i co-hosted it uh this past
weekend in hollywood florida and i know
florida is obviously the pinnacle of
what's going on here in politics and the
pinnacle of freedom and americanism but
the republican party is extremely rich
right now with a diverse set of people
and i mean diverse in the in the idea
set and in the i don't care about the
other thing but there were plenty of
latino people there and black people and
indian people and white people and asian
people and all of that stuff and gay
people and straight people
the the republican party is is actually
i think having a a beautiful renaissance
right now and trying to figure out how
you can take all of these disaffected
liberals all of these these sort of
non-political people who have been
mugged by democrat reality put them into
this new party and figure it out and
figure out how to work together those
differences that's what politics is all
about that's happening in the republican
party right now it really is but not if
you watch msnbc obviously you can't do
that
they're also weaponizing what else do
the democrats do they're they weaponize
the government against powerful people
that they disagree with so this is when
i tell you that it's not just trump when
they're always going after trump or
they're always going after desantis or
they're always going after tucker
carlson it's not just that they want to
take them out or jordan peterson right
we played that video yesterday he still
hasn't been taken out so that's good
right they try to take out but they're
they're actually not as effective at it
as they used to be but they will go for
anyone who stands up hey how about elon
musk check this headline from the daily
wire
federal government launches systemic
racism probe into tesla we got a little
info on that
california's department of fair
employment and housing said that it is
that it has received hundreds of
complaints from african-american workers
who claim they had been segregated to
the lowest levels of the workforce at
the company and lacked representation in
the ranks of executives senior officials
and managers tesla's most recent filings
with the sec indicated that the eeoc had
issued a finding that closely parallels
allegations from the state of california
yet tesla had formally called the dfeh
investigation misguided and an attempt
to generate publicity noting that every
one of the more than 50
discrimination accusations faced by
tesla over the past five years has been
debunked by the de uh the dfeh now the
reason i bring this up is obviously elon
musk has become wildly outspoken related
to politics he tried to buy twitter and
at the very least has exposed twitter to
be
completely fraudulent he has gone on the
record saying he would support ron
desantis he voted for mira myra flores
in uh in texas
uh first time he says he ever voted for
a republican so then what happens next
thing you know
the sec is looking into his company
about systemic racism and by the way
i don't know the full racial breakdown
of every tesla employee i don't know it
but if you just happen to hire people
based on uh their skills
their color will be irrelevant uh so if
you would like to work at a company
where they hire not the people who are
best skilled but based on their
sexuality or gender or color of skin
you're not going to get the best product
this is simply true
but that's a separate issue the issue
here is the gov this is what these
people do they weaponize the government
right this is the irs obama's irs going
after all the tea party groups they use
the levers of government to destroy
their opposition and why would you do
that because you have to distract from
the larger issues of course that they've
caused sort of like the uh recession or
as they call it the non-recession here's
black lesbian corrine jean-pierre saying
she's not even gonna tell you what
recession means
and what is exactly the white house's
definition of a recession again we don't
we don't def i'm not going to define it
from here i'm just going to leave it to
the nber as as we have stated how they
define uh recent recessions
i'm just saying that we're just not
going to define it we use the indicators
that the nber uh the national national
bureau of economic research has viewed
okay she's not going to define it but
whether she defines it or not there is a
definition of recession that has been
the commonly used definition of
recession for a hundred years or
something like that and it's basically
two quarters in a row where things are
not going up that's pretty much back to
back two of those recession that's
pretty much how it works uh here's more
from corinne jean-pierre
next week's a very big week for the
economy so i read the cea blog is the
white house trying to change the common
definition of a recession because next
thursday the gdp numbers coming out are
going to show that we've been in
recession so let me say this you know
the strength of our labor market along
with the other economic uh factors is
what what we generally see in a
recession or even a pre a pre what
is not what we generally see in a
recession or even a pre-recession
because we're seeing the strength of the
economy and the labor market so that's
really important to note that
it's just nothingness it's just endless
nothingness that's that was the whole
point of that clip like they will
literally define redefined words right
in front of you this is what they do but
you can't be surprised by this if
someone says the two plus two is five
you might start thinking geez i'm not
sure that i want to trust this person
when it comes to defining other words
here's a treasury secretary janet yellen
and i love showing clips of her because
uh a few months back she had hope that
we weren't going into recession i'd like
someone who's doing something about it
in charge of the treasury but she had
hope which it's always good to have hope
you gotta have hope right i've seen
shawshank redemption hope is good hope
is a special thing we all know it very
important dev hope otherwise you're not
going to get out of that jail that
you've been improperly imprisoned for
decades you got to have hope she has
hope by the way someone yesterday at the
end of the show remember they said that
she looks like uh the lemonhead guy from
the candy we checked it after she does
so i want you to take when you're done
watching the show today i want you to
take a picture of janet yellen and then
pull up the uh lemon head guy
her head because her head is kind of
like this and like this very lemon heady
anyway here's yellen um a common
definition of recession is two negative
quarters of gdp growth or at least
that's something that's been true in
past recessions when we've seen that
there has usually been a recession and
many economists
expect second quarter gdp to be negative
first quarter gdp was negative so we
could see that happen and that will be
closely watched but i do want to
emphasize
what a recession really means is a
broad-based contraction in the economy
and even if that number is negative we
are not in a recession now and
i i would you know warn that we should
be um not not characterizing that as a
result i understand that but you're
splitting hairs i mean if the technical
definition is two quarters of
contraction you're saying that's not a
recession that's not to take
no that's not the technical definition
yes it is the technical definition and
that's exactly what you said right
before that the technical definition if
the gross domestic product goes down
basically for two quarters in a row it's
a recession so she basically was like
the gross domestic product goes down two
quarters of a row it's a recession but
this thing which is what we know is
going down back-to-back two credit it's
not gonna happen
what i mean you know when chuck todd has
to ask you a follow-up question you
really stepped in it
here's the elderly man pretending to be
president talking about how we're not
going into recession even though
everyone knows we're going into a
recession mr president we're getting gdp
numbers on thursday how worried should
americans be
that we could be in a
recession we're not gonna be in a
recession uh in my view uh
we uh the employment rate is still one
of the lowest
we've had in history into the 3.6 area
uh we still find ourselves with people
investing
my hope is we go from this rapid growth
to steady growth
and uh so see we'll see some coming down
but i don't think we're going to uh god
willing i don't think we're going to see
recession
there's nothing more comforting than an
elderly man with a horrible camera angle
sitting back like this choking on his
own phlegm scratching his head while he
tells you that we're not going into a
recession which if you saw that episode
of seinfeld when people lie they touch
their face and the bigger the lie is the
higher up on their head that they
scratch or touch uh and he said well i
hope we're not going either
god these people are terrible but here's
a non-terrible person you may remember
my guest uh from a week or two ago
patrick bet david who is a phenomenal
entrepreneur
and
founder of valuetainment tv and he knows
an awful lot about the economy he had a
great twitter thread
on what's going on here let me read this
to you he said i called this six weeks
ago white house is afraid of recession
it's been known for decades that the
definition of recession is two
consecutive quarters of gdp declining
but the current administration is
working very hard to change the
definition
google definition of recession you'll
see the following trend almost every
dictionary starts with quote a recession
is often defined as real gdp falling for
two successive quarters but
they have a new sentence added to it
here it is but the national bureau of
economic research defines a recession as
a significant decline in economic
activity spread across the economy
lasting more than a few months normally
visible in real gdp real income
employment industrial production and
wholesale retail sales in other words
the white house believes is too lazy to
research for themselves very convenient
meanwhile the poor keep getting poorer
and politicians keep gaslighting low and
middle income families call a spade a
spade and a recession a recession so the
reason i thought this was important was
because hey of course
showing their nonsense like showing how
they don't believe what they're saying
how they will change words and
definitions right in front of you but i
thought what patrick uh pointed out
there about how now when you start
googling things you see different
definitions for things is really
interesting because this is the world
we're in right now where there's an
information war on top of everything
else where if it is known that a
recession was you know two consecutive
quarters of the gdp shrinking that's the
way we've always thought about it so now
you're you're a thoughtful person in
2022 and you want to find out well it
seems like janet yellen might be lying
or joe biden might be a little confused
i'm going to jump on the computer
machine and i'm going to do a little
typing and the clicking and all that
stuff and i'm going to find out what it
what it actually means but then if they
go in and through algorithms and through
big tech collusion can actually change
the definition in real time right in
front of you you will not know when a
recession is a recession all that being
said i would prefer not to be in a
recession alas here we are
but
let's do the positive part because
that's what we do here at the rubin
report it ain't working people are
seeing it and it ain't working
and even on cnn
they are starting to show it because
they can't hide it much longer chris
saliza
inflation affects every american
directly
the buy administration is trying to
point out the definition of a recession
is nuanced but i got to tell you i i
struggle with this i get that why they
want to do it from a political
perspective but like you can't fake this
no i was just i was laughing to myself
with the in my view thing that caitlyn
highlighted because it's like well in my
view i should be drafted into the nba
like
it doesn't really matter what you think
it's there's a there is a technical
definition two straight quarters of
negative economic growth
they clearly believe that that is likely
to come to pass later this week they're
trying to pre-budget to your point we
get why they're doing it politically
right
at the same time we have these terms for
reasons you don't have to like it of
course they don't like it because the
account you know a textbook joe biden's
handling of the economy was at 25 or 30
in our most recent poll like yeah it's a
problem for them this adds to the
problem
but you don't get to change the
nomenclature in the middle of
a campaign because it doesn't work for
you well then again your voters are
going to feel what they feel in their
lives exactly
so that guy chris eliza he's one of
these like nothing people like he gets
everything wrong trump derangement
syndrome oh you know just his whole
world has been based around trump but
i'd like to give credit where credit is
doing yes when they're telling you on
cnn hey hey uh biden administration you
can't actually just like redefine the
terms right in front of our eyes you
can't do that now of course they can
they'll just keep doing it because
they'll just keep lying and eventually
the media will just follow along because
they're lap dogs
but it hit me as i was watching that
clip hell
if if we were to say hell exist hell for
me would be sitting on a cnn panel every
day i don't i honestly believe there is
not one they could not pay me 10 million
dollars a year to do that job
10 million a year i would not do that
job you'd have to shoot me
and prop my dead carcass up sort of like
they do with biden every day they'd have
to just put me there weak in a bernie
style and i'd just be sitting there
between stealther and tapper and then my
head would be bobbling and that's what
they would do i would never take a job
to sit there with those people but the
point is okay so they lie about their
what an actual definition of recession
is and then they also have to lie about
their the results of their policies so
you know the democrats are no longer
biden is not defending the border
remember there was this orange man and
he wanted to defend the border and he
actually was defending the border but
they called him racist the entire time
and it was very odd because they also
said we were a systemically racist
country so why were all these people
trying to come here and nobody was
trying to leave the whole thing was very
very confusing but then eventually what
happens with all these democrat policies
is you start seeing the results of say
defunding the police say allowing all
these illegals to come into the country
say not
policing properly and all of the stuff
all of the stuff so what happens well in
new york here is the guy that they
thought was the moderate because he was
following a crazed socialist bill de
blasio here is new york city mayor eric
adams and he's upset because the city's
being overrun by these immigrants that
they keep letting in why
we can't have of the historical um i
believe people should be housed but just
don't house them on my block
everyone blocked everyone's block is
going to be impacted by this and so we
have to add our
advocacy
uh with our
ability to help our neighbors and we
need everyone on board with this you
know because as i stated last week our
schools are going to be impacted
our health care system is going to be
impacted
uh our infrastructure is going to be
impacted
but we're willing to do our job and
we're going we're going to do our job
and we're going to need all new yorkers
to be with us on this
here can i can i curse today can i do
one f bomb today i'm getting i'm getting
the okay get the [ __ ] out of new york
city if you live in new york city if
four years or however many years of de
blasio wasn't enough
and and all the lockdowns and the crime
and what's going on on the subways
wasn't enough do you hear what this man
is saying
we're going to do what we got to do what
do you mean for the people that voted
you in for the citizens the legal
citizens of new york city or for all the
people who are rampaging through who
then you're gonna give all these
services and what are you saying you're
gonna you're gonna move them into the
upper east side you're gonna move them
next to george jefferson and wheezy i've
been trying to get a jefferson's
reference in in a while you know what
i'm saying
is that what you're saying that is what
you're saying you're going to do what
you got to do for people who are not
citizens of this country you must leave
new york city if you are a sane person
they will take all of your money they
will move criminals next door to you and
they'll probably eventually kill you
that's what they're doing that's what
they're doing and they'll lock you down
and the rest of it but it ain't working
that's why this is the positive part of
the show it ain't working because enough
people are seeing it and people are
fleeing and new york city is losing so
many people because new york you know if
you live in new york city and you're
making money so you're a productive
person you're paying federal income tax
you're paying a state new york income
tax you're also paying new york city tax
often you could be taxed at something
like 60 i mean it's it's completely
bananas people are getting the hell out
they're bringing all their resources to
florida florida is flourishing pretty
freaking fantastic
new york city has a four percent tax to
just live in the city at certain
caps of wealth i mean bananas but anyway
people are seeing it and the machine is
breaking down right in front of our eyes
here is corey bush she is a
representative from missouri she is in
the squad the media loves her because
she is a big government democrat who
thinks everything is racist and even she
now
she ain't into joe biden and she's not
happy that this clip got out there
because she gets asked about biden watch
what happens to one of the advisors
yelling in her ear and then take a look
do you want to see joe biden run for a
second term
yeah i you know that's an easy question
that's not going to take long do you
want to see joel i don't want to answer
that question because we have not that's
not yeah i don't want to answer that
question okay um i mean he's the
president and he has the right to to run
for a second term absolutely that's good
i don't want to i don't i don't want i'd
rather you not do that right so you got
like two minutes
yeah i know i got to get to
does that tell you everything you need
to know about how the media operates
with all of this stuff like i don't want
to answer that question that's not that
i'm not going to talk about that
it's all just they they hate biden
they're done with biden he was a useful
idiot to usher in their nonsense and the
question is can biden's administration
just demolish everything so somehow
these people can pick up the pieces or
will we fight back
i think we're going to fight back the
point of all of this ladies and
gentlemen is that their campaign tactics
are falling flat they're not covering up
the recession that they caused even if
they change the definition of recession
even if the media calls them out for it
and the democratic leaders are now
calling out their own buffoonish
president and they want to get rid of
him so this it all sounds kind of scary
to some degree again we'd all like the
machine to be working properly i would
find something else to do if it did
there's other things i could do i don't
know what i could do what can i do
i feel like i'd
work in a field i like gardening i
really like gardening i would probably
be a gardener or a professional tequila
taster that would be good but the point
is people are waking up to it and that
my friends is good uh we got some
comments from the uh reuben report
locals community and then stick around
for a cold close it's an oldie but a
goodie as they say in radio the
mainstream media is already losing their
collective minds because they are seeing
the writing on the wall for the midterms
they are about to lose and are desperate
to try to turn it into some kind of
victory even if their people lose badly
yeah that does seem to be generally
what's going on here but again they can
do anything beforehand so you got to
make sure you stay focused you got to
make sure you vote i will also tell you
that you know when i was at sunshine
summit and turning point
this past weekend i met an awful lot of
people who are running for school boards
which is fantastic that's showing you
that regular people these are not people
who are inherently interested in
politics they're just going whoa whoa i
actually would prefer that my son
remained say a boy than turn into a
chick so i'm going to get involved at
the school level so this is this is good
stuff tiger says michigan wants to be in
contention with california for the most
abortion friendly states in the country
the proposed amendment that will likely
be on the no november ballot is full
term no parental consent yeah i mean
that's not surprising to me ju remember
the democrats just what was it two three
weeks ago tried to push a bill through
the house that was going to be no
restrictions on abortion at the federal
level i mean it's absolutely insane
regardless of whether you think uh it's
federal or state or anything else that
you would have no restrictions and also
the thing about parental consent man
they want to they literally want to
chemically cr castrate your kids put
them on puberty blockers and then make
sure that your 15 year old daughter can
get an abortion without you know it that
like that's what they want
you think that do you think that the
train is out of control here
math knight says beverly hills voted not
to enforce mass mandates well that's
good to hear that's good to hear i don't
know that that can be overridden by the
la
department of health or whatever's going
on over there but i guess a little good
news out of california is nice every now
and again that does remind me i have to
put a little cash in the escape cali jar
guys part one of my interview of former
white house press secretary when they
used to be saying back in the day uh ari
fleischer is up right now uh you know i
am going off the grid for august so this
friday we'll have a big massive
crazy huge
adjective-laced show uh for you the
usual time uh then i'm gonna be doing
drinks with the locals community uh a
little bit after that that will be my
official leave and then i'm gone until
september 1st we've already booked the
guests we've got our local studio being
built in miami we'll be doing that in
person and i'll be getting back to some
in-person interviews and a whole bunch
more and we'll make some other
announcements and all that good stuff
and now we leave you on this tuesday
because we didn't bludgeon you enough
with cnn
and the view today here's one more
see dr jill
becomes a surgeon general his wife
yeah
joe biden's wife because she's you know
she would never do it but she yeah she's
a hell of a doctor she's an amazing
doctor she's a doctor and phd yeah i
don't i don't know i could be wrong
i think she knows she's she's a teacher
but
you know